I always imagined the story of my first
love would be a magical one not a
cautionary tale I just started college
in Chicago I was so fun and carefree and
feisty I thought I was invincible and
ready to take over the world
I was fearless and then I met him he was
so handsome and charming our first date
was a walk in the park I remember he
pointed out that I had a booger in my
nose and I was super embarrassed he
asked me to be his girlfriend a few
months later and of course I said yes
and that's when things changed I slowly
stopped hanging out with my friends it
was always just me and him and when as
far as him creating a rift and ruining
the trust between my best friend and I
me and her didn't speak for almost two
years he would get upset at me and he
would break my cellphone so I couldn't
talk to anyone he was convinced that I
was cheating on him he would get upset
at me for saying hi to my guy friends on
the street but that should have been
assigned right there he was emotionally
abusive and he made me feel like every
decision I made was wrong
I felt that nothing I did could make him
happy the first time he hit me I was
convinced that it was my fault and that
might attitude made him upset and maybe
if I didn't talk back things would get
better between us the moment I knew that
I had to get out of their relationship
was when he knocked me down and I fell
and I hit my head it wasn't the first
time he hit me but it was the first time
I felt really scared I called my best
friend and I finally told her the truth
and she said she was coming to get me
and I was staying with her in the
suburbs I was packing he came home early
and was livid when he saw that I was
leaving I didn't realize the situation
got out of hand until he pulled a
kitchen knife on me he told me if you
leave me you're gonna kill me so he may
as well kill me now
and only then did my brain register
danger my best friend came at the nick
of time she called the cops
and that's when he slit his wrists the
cops came and took him to the hospital I
felt so guilty I was an empty shell of
myself
I was apologizing for my very existence
I had no voice had no identity I was
seeking approval from everyone except
myself much to my regret I did end up
going back to him a few months later we
were off and on again
there was a tug of war between my
loneliness and depression and
vulnerability I was trying to find peace
with myself and I wanted to forgive him
so I wasn't carrying the hatred that I
felt for him I found myself in an all
too familiar situation but I felt that
he wasn't trying to knock me down to
size again and things with us weren't
really done until about another year and
a half later when he moved to a
different state I always thought how did
this happen to someone like me I was a
good girl I wasn't raised in a household
with domestic abuse
all of my friends had no relationships
what was wrong with me why did he feel
he had to hit me once he was gone for
good
I rediscovered the things that made me
happy again I threw myself into my
career I had new friends and love
interests I had a therapist who I saw
once a week she helped me build myself
back together again if you're going
through this I want you to know to pay
attention to the signs it's hard because
your emotions are clouded and you're in
love the love is supposed to make you
feel good you should always lift you up
listen to your friends they care don't
forget that you are still a good person
because you deserve all the happiness in
the world and you're worth it